thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode
hey crazies emma and i occasionally play
this dice game called
farkle you roll a bunch of six sided
dice and different roles give you
different scores
you know it's a dice game but the scores
for the various roles don't seem to line
up with their likelihood
we've gotten six of a kind several times
but neither one of us has ever gotten a
straight yet
six of a kind is worth twice as much
is our evidence just anecdotal or is the
one through six straight
actually less likely and if it is less
likely
maybe we can fix the scoring
[Music]
this episode was made possible by the
generous support of our patrons and
youtube members
all right i suppose i should explain the
rules of the game real quick
if you already know them feel free to
jump to this time code right here
in farkle you start with six six-sided
dice
technically the game came with these
dice but we're gonna be doing enough
counting today i didn't think we needed
to also count pips
so i swapped out the dice with ones with
numbers anyway
you roll and keep as many of the scoring
dice as you'd like
these are all the possible ways you can
score
the next step is what makes this game
interesting
once you've selected your scoring dice
you can roll the remaining dice again
if you want it's a gamble though if you
get more scoring dice
you can keep those too they go in a
separate group from the first roll
though you don't get to count them all
together
you can even repeat and roll the
remaining dice again
but if your roll doesn't get any scoring
dice that's called a
farkle and it voids all your previous
rolls from that round
you get zero points it's pretty simple
and it's one of the few games that m and
i can actually play in the morning
during breakfast
waking up is hard looking at all the
scoring rolls
we can see there's already some obvious
problems
a triplet is equally likely regardless
of the number
yet they're all worth a different number
of points so
we already know we're going to have to
adjust the scoring at least a little
for a proper adjustment we'll need to
know the probabilities of
all the possible roles and here they are
huh
yo what's the hold up i i'm working on
it but there are forty six thousand six
hundred and fifty six
possible rolls on six dice alone okay
okay
just send it over when you have it it's
fine we'll get through this together
wait a minute 46 000 possible rolls
that can't be right six dice with six
possible states each
whoa i guess he's right
maybe we'll start with one six sided die
and work our way up
the only way to score with one die is to
roll a one
or a five since there are only six
possible outcomes
each of them will only have a 1 in 6
chance of happening
with 2 dice there are 6 to the 2 or 36
possible outcomes
which seems easy enough to count
manually just set up a 6x6 matrix
where the rows represent one of the dice
and the columns represent the other
there's only one way to get two ones one
way to get two fives
two ways to get a one and a five eight
ways to get a single one
and eight ways to get a single five the
rest of the rolls are farkles
which is a huge chunk of the rolls it is
very likely for you to farkle if you
only have two dice left to roll
unfortunately this method isn't going to
scale very well
three dice would be a six by six by six
matrix
how would you even use this thing to
count i don't want to sit and calculate
it all
that's what stats clone is for let's
make a computer do this for us
it's time for some python we'll include
some text labels
define what the dice look like and let
it know what can score and what can't
it doesn't matter which die rolls what
so we'll need to include all the scoring
permutations
then we just needed to output the
results yep that ought to do it
and go we've got all the possible roles
in a list
the total number of possible roles looks
good here's all the scoring rules and
how often they occur
and there are 16 ways to sparkle that
all matches our matrix method so
i'm feeling pretty good about this what
about three dice
that should be easy enough we're going
to use the same code as before and just
add an extra die
actually now that i'm thinking about
this let's sort the arrays in numerical
order
that way when we get down to the scoring
conditions we don't have to think of
every permutation
and go it says here there's 216
possible roles which is 6 to the 3 so
that checks out
the rest of the counts for the scoring
rolls look reasonable
and there are 60 ways to farkle what
about four dice
let's do it you know i should be able to
scale this up better with some recursion
we'll just define a function that calls
itself and go
well crap okay never mind
back to our original code add a fourth
die and
wow this this is a lot of scoring rules
let's be strategic with our if-then
conditions and just count similar
elements
and go oh i needed a little time to
think about that one
anyway we've got counts that all look
reasonable there are four extra ways to
get a triple one than a triple two
because it didn't get counted up here
the same goes for triple fives
they didn't get counted here a single
one is just as likely as a single five
i think we're good what about yes yes we
can do five dice
add a die to the code add a few extra
scoring possibilities
and go
holy moly that's a lot of possible rules
this is getting tough six dice
and go
go and go
well this is taking a while okay there
we go i was getting worried
i suppose i don't know if any of these
have been miscounted i got them finished
wow that's some great timing thanks
you're welcome
oh a spreadsheet wow nice
thanks you you're going to show them my
binomial coefficients right
well i suppose that's only fair oh okay
i'm super excited about the spreadsheet
but
we'll get back to it shortly statsclone
managed to calculate all these by hand
using something called a binomial
coefficient
at least that's the fancy mathematical
name for them i prefer to call them
combinations
there is a formula for it chock full of
factorials but we're not going to use it
there are only six dice and each of
those dice can only be in one of six
states
the input numbers are small it's going
to be easier just to use pascal's
triangle
each number in this triangle is the sum
of the two numbers above it
if we go down six rows we'll have all
the numbers we could possibly need for
this video
in bracket form the terms would all look
like this it lets you see the pattern
but it doesn't actually show you the
answers
so we'll just write the triangle with
the answers and color code for reference
the total number you're choosing from is
the row
the number you're choosing is the
colored diagonal
the combination of four choose one can
be found here
the combination of six choose three can
be found here
easy peasy now usually combinations like
this are explained using playing cards
rather than dice because playing cards
are simpler
this card is a five of hearts and that's
all it'll ever be
if you want to choose a hand of 5 cards
from a deck of 52
all you need is one combination to
figure out how many possible ways that
can happen
52 choose five dice
like you'd find in the game of farkle
are more complicated
each one of them can be in one of six
possible states
that means we're not only choosing dice
we're also choosing numbers
on those dice we can still use
combinations but we're going to need
more than one because we're making more
than one choice
say we wanted to know the number of ways
we could roll a single one
on two dice first we choose one die
from two dice then we choose one number
from four possible numbers
it can't be a five because five scores
all by itself that's a different role
anyway we're choosing one number out of
four possible numbers
it's a separate combination multiplying
them together
you get two times four equals eight
which is exactly what we got with the
python code
but say we wanted to know the number of
ways you could roll a one
on three dice we choose one die
out of three dice then one number out of
four numbers
then another number out of four numbers
three
times four times four equals 48 which
matches python
the game of farkle doesn't start with 2
dice or 3 dice though
it starts with 6. we need to be really
careful with the combination rules if we
have that many dice
rule number 1 any dice you choose musket
dice combinations
that includes specific dice that are
chosen and
dice that are grouped unknown ungrouped
dice
don't need a dice combination because
you're not choosing them
you're leaving them be rule number two
any dice that are unknown must get
number combinations
groups of unknown dice only need one
number combination for the whole group
keep these rules in mind as we try six
dice
how about rolling a four of a kind with
a pair that's a dice combo for the four
of a kind
a diced combo for the pair a number
combo for the four of a kind
and a number combo for the pair next we
grab all the values we need from
pascal's triangle
yep all four of them are there then we
get 15 times
one times six times five equals four
fifty
okay okay let's try something a little
trickier
like two triplets just like last time
you'll need two dice combos and two
number combos which gives us 600.
wait that's not right my python code and
the spreadsheet both say 300.
oh i see what happened we actually only
need
one number combo for both groups of dice
see
when you have two groups of the same
size you don't know which one is which
which means if you do a number combo for
each of them you're gonna over count
i'll just add this into a rules list so
we don't make this mistake again
okay how about three pairs you'll need
three dice combos
and one number combo that gives us 1800
which
matches what we got before okay
i think we've seen enough of those back
to the spreadsheet
all right so we've got the list of all
possible scoring rules
the number of points they're officially
worth and the number of ways they occur
divide the number of ways a specific
role can occur
by the total number of possible roles
and you've got yourself a probability
first of all the one through six
straight is way more common than six of
a kind
like by a lot so the evidence i based
this video on was completely anecdotal
which is good to know i guess but
overall
there still doesn't appear to be any
correlation between
probability and score that's easy enough
to fix though just add some more columns
to keep things simple we won't do
anything special with plus ones or plus
fives on larger roles
by that i just mean that like a triple
two with a single five will just be
whatever the triple two
is worth plus whatever the five is worth
nothing special because you rolled them
together
speaking of triplets for consistency
they should all be worth the same number
of points
because they're all equally likely as
far as i'm concerned it makes the most
sense to define the lowest possible
scoring roll and then
scale everything up from there in normal
farkle
a roll of 5 is worth 50 points let's
leave that one alone
a roll of 1 is just as likely as a roll
of 5
so it should also be worth 50 points the
rest of the rolls
can just be a ratio of values from the
probability column
copy that up for all the rolls and whoa
whoa whoa
six of a kind is way too big let's bring
that down a little with a square root
yeah yeah that that looks better copy
that down for all the rolls and bingo
bango
although these aren't the prettiest
numbers in the world so i think we can
take some liberties and round a little
yeah there we go much better you're
gonna play it now right
sure i suppose that's a good idea
okay that was actually pretty boring
here are some things we realized while
we were playing
by using the six dice roll to scale out
the points i hadn't taken into
consideration
how often a role comes up during your
entire turn
roles like six of a kind and a straight
can only happen on your first roll
whereas you get several chances to get
triplets on your later gamble rolls
but i don't think that would have made
the game more interesting
scaling the points by probability made
all of the scores hover around a few
hundred points
there wasn't a lot of variation the high
scoring rolls
are extremely rare we actually scored
the game the traditional way too
just for comparison notice the
difference
it might be more obvious if i show you
the running totals graph instead
without one of those rare high scoring
rolls there's very little chance of an
unexpected comeback
if someone gets behind at the beginning
they're likely to stay behind the entire
game
in the end m's win margin using my
scoring was
proportional to the traditional scoring
it just wasn't as fun to play
so as it turns out farkle already has
good scoring rules
even if they're not statistically
accurate honestly
it already has good scoring because it's
not statistically accurate
so which scoring would you like to use
mine or the traditional
also is it still farkle if we use
different scoring
discuss thanks for liking and sharing
this video
a special thanks goes out to supporters
like josiah gleaton glenn northrup
and prodan who provide the stability
that helps make the show possible
whether you support on patreon or a
youtube membership you are appreciated
thank you for making it possible for
this to be my job
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy want to
learn something new this year
then check out brilliant it's a website
and app that makes learning
interactive accessible and fun i'd
recommend starting with probability
fundamentals
where you can get used to counting
outcomes before you move on to the
harder stuff
they even have a course called
programming with python if that's what
attracted you to my video
with over 60 courses to choose from
there's something for everyone
these courses are laid out like a story
and broken into pieces
so you can tackle them one bit at a time
if you really want to learn something
and have it stick then you need practice
does this sound like a service you'd
like to use if so
go to brilliant.org science asylum so
they know you heard about them from me
they're also offering the first 200 of
you 20
off an annual subscription
if earth ended up inside the sun there
would be drag on it and its orbit would
decay
well yes that's technically true but the
density of the sun
is already extremely low let alone when
it expands into a red giant
the earth will vaporize long before that
drag can do anything significant
to its orbit anyway thanks for watching